Tenemos un cuadrado dividido en 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9 secciones iguales, y ya hemos visto
que si coloreamos una de estas secciones, si
seleccionamos una de estas partes, supongamos
esta de en medio, es 1 de las 9 secciones iguales,
así que si alguien te pregunta qué fracción del
entero representa esta sección cuadrangular morada
puedes contestar que representa 1/9 del entero,
esta sección representa 1/9. Ahora, ¿qué pasará
si coloreamos más secciones? Vamos a colorear
esta otra sección y esta otra y esta otra en la
esquina inferior. Ahora, ¿qué fracción del entero
hemos coloreado? Bueno, ya hemos visto que cada
una de estas representa 1/9, esta sección es 1/9,
esta otra es 1/9 y cada una de estas representa
1/9. ¿Cuántos novenos tenemos coloreados? Bueno,
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4 de ellos, ahora tenemos un
total de 4/9 coloreados, 4 de las 9 secciones
iguales están coloreadas, entonces 4/9 del
entero están coloreados. Ahora, hagamos
las cosas más interesantes. Por acá tenemos 5
secciones iguales y vamos a colorear 5 de ellas,
tenemos: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, y ya sabemos que cada una
de estas secciones representa 1/5, aquí hay otro
quinto y otro y otro y otro. ¿Qué tanto hemos
coloreado? Bueno, tenemos 5 de las 5 secciones
iguales coloreadas, dicho de otra manera,
tenemos 5/5 coloreados, y tal vez me digas:
"Espera, espera, si tenemos 5 de las 5 secciones
iguales coloreadas, si tenemos 5/5 coloreados,
entonces tenemos todo el entero coloreado". Y eso
es completamente cierto: 5/5 = 1 entero. Ahora,
lo que quiero que hagas es que pauses este
video y escribas en un pedazo de papel,
o al menos lo pienses, ¿qué fracción de
cada uno de estos enteros está coloreada?
Vayamos con el primero. Tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
secciones iguales, y podemos ver que hay 1, 2, 3,
4 de ellas coloreadas, por lo tanto, 4/6 de esta
figura están coloreados. Vayamos al siguiente:
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 secciones iguales y 4 de
ellas están coloreadas, aquí tenemos 4/5 partes
del círculo coloreadas. En esta figura tenemos
2 secciones iguales y ambas están coloreadas,
entonces tenemos 2 mitades, 2/2 de
esta figura coloreados. Una vez más,
si 2/2 están coloreados, entonces todo está
coloreado, esto representa 1 entero. Ahora,
en esta figura de aquí podemos estar tentados
a decir "Tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4 secciones y 1, 2,
3 de ellas están coloreadas, tal vez esto de color
rojo represente 3/4 de la figura"; pero recuerda:
las secciones deben ser iguales, y puedes ver
que esta sección roja es mucho más grande que las
otras tres juntas, es la más grande, por lo tanto,
no tenemos 4 secciones iguales aquí, entonces,
al menos por cómo lo dibujamos no podemos decir
que la parte coloreada represente 3/4 partes.